simon it's so wonderful to see you
because we have so much to discuss
canada's got talent is massive here
people are absolutely loving it i mean
yes everyone loves us so tell me
how is howie holding down the fort are
you proud of him and he's taking care of
canada
oh yeah i mean you know we had a long
lots of conversations about him being on
the show
um he probably spoke more about the
canadian shirt than he did about the
american show when we did the judging
together but i did say to him
because i'm going to judge the final you
can't tell me anything about the
contestants because if i'm going to come
in and be like a judge what am i
supposed to be doing then it's going to
be i want to meet them first time i
don't want to hear anything about them
it's got to be a total surprise and you
know what how he's like he can't keep
his mouth shut but
that was the promise but he's super
proud and he's loved the show i mean
really really happy oh that's so great
and yes you're joining him in niagara
falls you're gonna be part of the finale
i mean
are you do you have an indication i hate
asking this question but who will win it
all when you look at the talent you must
have a perspective of like who's going
to take it no i have absolutely no idea
because you know
in the past um other people have joined
our shows you know like as a guest judge
and they do all their homework and blah
blah blah blah and i i'm the opposite i
don't want to know anything so it's like
when i do auditions you know on the
other shows
i meet people for the first time you
make your own impression
and for me i think it's just more
interesting not knowing anything about
anyone
so how do you define talent then what
what is it well that's a good question
actually um i mean you've got to think
about the audience you know who are the
audience going to like everyone has you
know different tastes i mean that's the
great thing about the show i mean i mean
there's you have every kind of genre of
people coming on the show and animals
and god knows everything so um
it's
i mean i obviously love the singers i
love groups um i love the animal acts um
but
mostly i like being surprised and that's
why i really really had to be strict
with myself about the show which is i
don't want to know anything i mean i
know the shows are here i know that
people love the show and that's why i'm
really excited to be coming over and i
hope i like everyone
let's talk about liking everyone because
you're going to be joining new judges
lilly singh hallie carnell trish how
does it feel to be sitting down at a
judge's table with a whole new group of
people it's tough i i remember when i
joined agt which was in
2016 and it was like my first day at
school you know like they all knew each
other and i was like the new boy and i
came in and what did they hate me and
actually thank god we all got great and
i had a great time but i think uh when
you're gonna do something like this you
really for me anyway i like to not know
anything and just go into it and then
just give my opinion on the night which
is going to be really interesting
yeah america's got talent this is what
the 17th season now congratulations
thank you you got to explain to me simon
that feeling of being the judge and
talent coming on stage and having that
look in their face of believing that
it's possible it must be incredible for
you to see that
well you know the expression we use a
lot is the next three minutes you know
can change your life and i've seen it
happen on so many occasions um sometimes
you have people like you said come on
and they're very confident and they've
kind of got that still in their eyes
other times people like susan boyle
they'd come on stage i thought she was
going to be terrible because she was so
nervous
and then she was amazing and i look
really stupid afterwards but you know i
i love that feeling it's that um it's
that first impression i i love i love
that moment um because everyone thinks
on the show that we know who's coming on
coming on on the series i genuinely
haven't got a clue until i meet them at
that moment
and then i just asked loads of questions
i've no idea what they're going to do
and then wait and see what happens and
sometimes it's great and sometimes it's
terrible and you know on a final you
know you know
you know we're going to see in the next
few days
finals anything can happen people who
are super confident get really nervous
um or other people who maybe weren't so
good they they
they just
it all changes on the night everything's
unpredictable so i'm really excited i
haven't done this you know like be a
guest judge for a long long time so it's
going to be fun i know canada's really
excited about you coming down and have
you been to niagara falls before
no
um i've been to canada quite a few times
um but this is the first time i think
it's gonna be brilliant
did you know it's a honeymoon
destination
it's a wallet it's a honeymoon
destination niagara falls did you know
that i think i knew that um i'm coming
on my own um i'm not married yet so are
you you're not married yet no i mean i i
keep reading i'm gonna get married next
week next month i mean
uh
it's news to me
so you're getting married in june you're
going to london you're getting married
is that the news
we have a date on it no but it does make
me laugh because people keep calling me
and say why haven't i been invited to
the wedding because we haven't planned
it yet
it's amazing what you read on social
media like i was confused is he married
you're not married and so i was like you
know it's a great honeymoon destination
just get it all done in one shot you
know what i just go with the flow i love
it i love it um one of the things our
audience really wanted to know was about
jonathan goodwin and if he had a chance
to connect with him after everything
that's happened to him well i'm glad you
asked i mean he is the most
extraordinary human being i've got to
tell you i mean when this happened it
was horrific i wasn't there when it
actually happened the accident but you
know i i got the call
and uh it was
you know traumatic to say the least uh
and then after about i think it was
three days uh i went up to see him in
his hospital you know in the hospital um
and what was amazing this is like i said
only a few days after the accident we're
talking like we're talking now i mean he
was i mean he was bashed up
we would we spent two hours together we
were talking about everything he was
very philosophical and um he is like i
said he genuinely is the most
extraordinary person um and you know we
we we talk a lot um obviously i check in
on him um he was on a tv show recently
uh which i saw a few days ago and he
looks incredible i mean having said that
i mean it was a bad accident um and uh
but you know he is dealing with it i
think as as best as he possibly can but
yeah uh it was one of the worst things
that i've i've ever had to well i wasn't
the one who was injured but you know he
is a great guy we've known him for a
long long time so it was very very
difficult but thank god
um and i think he's you know on the mend
mentally i think he's in a really really
good place
and uh if anyone's going to get through
this it's him because he's a very very
strong man
and i i think that's still great because
i notice that simon you stay connected
with the talent and you you take the
time even after the show which is so
great that you do that because i think
that's really important too oh he would
do the same for me i mean he is just you
know he's a really really decent guy and
um it was one of those things you you
you're never prepared for until it
happens and then when it happens you
just try and do everything you should be
doing
um and uh you know it was um
yeah it it it was it was bad but
hopefully you know uh
like i said i don't know anything
in detail about the physical injuries i
can tell you mentally he is doing well
in like i said and he's got an
incredible fiancee by the way i mean she
is an amazing person and we connected
you know through this whole you know
accident so
he's lucky to have her and she's lucky
to have him
you know there's a lot of talent in
canada so i thought we were here
so much talent i thought we'd do a fun
little canadian talent quiz what do you
think
uh
yeah
okay you're ready
i'm not prepared for anything this is
going to be a really good example of no
clue do you know canadians okay what
canadian singer song uh saying my heart
will go on in titanic
sitting dear
that was an easy one easy one
who starred in a notebook ryan reynolds
ryan gosling or seth rogen
second one
the second one ryan gosling very good
yes yes two more who is just there
no you're doing so good who star oh
sorry who eats peaches from georgia
shawn mendes justin bieber or drake
justin bieber yes
okay this is it meghan markle was on the
show deal or no deal who was the host
will our happy
mandel
you're awesome simon i can't wait to see
you on the show we're so excited are you
gonna are you gonna be there yes i'll be
there on monday and i think the finale
is on tuesday so i'll come by and say hi
to you all right fantastic thank you so
much take care of yourself yeah and
thanks for doing this it was great to
talk to you
you